ein Hinweis bevor es losgeht in diesem
Podcast werden unter anderem
Verstümmelungen und Kannibalismus
thematisiert denjenigen denen solche
Schilderungen zu nahe gehen raten wir
vom Hören ab
hallo mein Name ist Sky Duo und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
moin und mein Name ist Natalie Strauß
ich bin Radiomoderatorin und werde im
täglichen Geschäft oft mit sehr
schrecklichen Verbrechen konfrontiert
manche Fälle sind so gruselig dass man
sie lieber als frei erfundenen Halloween
Film abspeichern würde damit ich nicht
allein bin mit Mord und Totschlag habe
ich auch heute wieder Moderator Mirko
Kasimir an meiner Seite Mirko schön dass
du auch heute wieder dabei bist hallo
grüß Dich Natalie und hallo liebe
höhererinnen und Hörer ja ich freue mich
auch
und es gibt Geschichten die sogar Jahre
später noch fest in unseren Köpfen
sitzen die sich aufgrund ihrer
Grausamkeit besonders eingeprägt haben
der Fall von Armin Meiwes bestimmt im
Frühjahr 2006 die Medien und ich habe
diesen Prozess immer noch so deutlich
vor Augen als wäre es wirklich gestern
gewesen vom Gericht erscheint ein
gefasst wirkender 44-jähriger Mann mit
etwas schütterem mittelblonden Haar und
gut sitzenden schwarzen Anzug er zeigt
überhaupt gar keine Spur von Nervosität
das Urteil
lebenslange Freiheitsstrafe wegen Mordes
und Störung der Totenruhe
eine nette Formulierung fürs Schlachten
und danach essen eines Menschen Armin
meibes ist besser bekannt als der
Kannibale von Rotenburg das Urteil fällt
2006 die Tat selbst begeht myvis viel
früher
[Musik]
es ist der frühe Morgen des 10 märz 2001
als Armin Mais neben dem toten Körper
des 43-Jährigen Berliner
Diplom-Ingenieurs Bernd brandesknied und
den Psalm 23 aus der Bibel betet
der Herr ist mein Hirte er wird nichts
mangeln er lässt mich lagern auf grünen
Auen und führt mich zum Ruheplatz am
Wasser meine Lebenskraft bringt er
zurück er führt mich auf Faden der
Gerechtigkeit getreu seinem Namen auch
wenn ich gehe im finsteren Tal ich
fürchte kein Unheil
finster sind seine Pfade allemal doch
das Mordopfer Bernd Brandis ist kein
gewöhnliches Opfer er scheinbar aus
freien Stücken aus Berlin zu Mais nach
Kassel gereist in der festen Absicht von
ihm getötet und verspeist zu werden ein
Wunsch der absolut absurd und
schrecklich scheint aber anscheinend gar
nicht mal so selten vorkommt Mirko in
was für Kreisen verkehrt Armin Mais und
wie ist es denn zu dieser Tat überhaupt
gekommen ja Mais und Brandis haben sich
auf einer Internetplattform für
Kannibalismus kennengelernt natürlich
ich glaube dir geht's wahrscheinlich
genauso aber bis zu diesem Fall hatte
ich überhaupt keine Ahnung das ist sowas
überhaupt gibt
in diesem Chatrooms und Foren tauschen
sich Menschen aus die entweder den
Wunsch haben zu schlachten oder
geschlachtet zu werden allein schon
diese Wortwahl klingt absolut
schauerlich
bei manchen Nutzern mag das reine oft
sexuell motivierte Fantasie sein andere
dagegen verbinden damit verdammt ernst
gemeinte konkrete Wünsche
Bernd Brandes nennt sich online Kato und
seine Anzeige soll in etwa so geklungen
haben
jordina ich biete mich an mich von euch
bei lebendigem Leib verspeisen zu lassen
wer es wirklich will braucht ein echtes
Opfer
dieser Wunsch klingt ganz nach dem von
Armin Meiwes und er antwortet als Franky
dass er in einem einsamen Haus lebe und
diese Schlachtung gern durchführen
möchte
dann dreht sich mir der Magen um aber
bevor wir auf die Tat zu sprechen kommen
müssen wir natürlich noch mal erzählen
wie Armin mai ist der Mensch werden
konnte der geworden ist
einiges ist in der Kindheit auf jeden
Fall schon schief gelaufen Meiwes Vater
der dritte Ehemann seiner Mutter hat
alles für ihn bedeutet er war ein
richtiges Papa Kind als Armin 8 Jahre
alt ist verlässt der Vater von heute auf
morgen die Familie Armin beschreibt in
einem Interview eindrücklich wie er
damals nebenan auf dem Feld gespielt hat
als plötzlich sein Vater und seine
Mutter im Streit rausgerannt sind der
Vater in ein Auto gestiegen ist und
einfach weg war und Armin ist ihm sogar
noch weint und schreiend hinterher
gerannt da bricht mir echt das Herz
und zu etwa derselben Zeit zieht dann
auch noch der heißgeliebte Bruder aus ja
und das löst natürlich was in ihm aus
und das scheint einiges zu sein denn
durch den Verlust seiner männlichen
Bezugspersonen zerbricht Meiwes heile
Welt von einem Moment auf den anderen
der Junge lebt bei seiner Mutter weiter
er beschreibt sich selbst als Lausbub
der auch meine Ohrfeige von Mama
kassiert hat weil er einfach ein frecher
Kerl gewesen ist
mehr und mehr zieht er sich in seine
eigene Welt zurück eine Welt die nur
Armin kennt und niemandem etwas davon
mitteilt er erschafft sich einen
imaginären Freund einen imaginären
kleinen Bruder mit dem er seine Sorgen
teilen kann und um den er sich kümmert
in seiner Vorstellung sieht der aus wie
einer seiner Schulkameraden
das kann ich aber sogar verstehen ich
meine der hat seinen Vater und sein
Bruder verloren und schafft sich
natürlich Ersatz wenn auch nur im Kopf
das haben aber auch viele Kinder für
eine gewisse Zeit mal so ein imaginären
Freund meist tauchen die aber für eine
kurze Zeit auf und verschwinden dann
einfach wieder gehört bei mehr Kindern
als man denkt zur ganz normalen
Entwicklung dazu aber meist allerdings
zwischen zwei und siebenjährigen Armin
war bereits acht Jahre alt oder etwas
älter und diese Fantasie verschwindet
bei ihm halt nicht sie verändert sich ja
die Vorstellung vom imaginären Bruder
reicht Armin irgendwann nicht mehr aus
er wünscht sich jemanden in sich
aufzunehmen jemand soll Teil von ihm
werden damit er nie wieder allein sein
muss
armin Meiwes berichtet wir als
Jugendlicher eine Robinson Crusoe
Verfilmung gesehen hat in der junge
Männer in einen Sturm geraten einer
stirbt daraufhin will der andere den
Toten aufessen um den Freund zu Ehren
wie Meiwes beschreibt diese Filmszene
lässt ihn nicht mehr los durch diverse
Hausschlachtungen aus der Nachbarschaft
ist Schlachten für ihn per se nicht
schlimmes er ist schon als Kind dabei
wenn Schweine getötet zum ausbluten
aufgehängt und verarbeitet werden mit 16
17 werden seine Wünsche immer
gewalttätiger er onaniert während er
sich vorstellt wie er einen
Schulkameraden vergewaltigt und dann
tötet
das Gefühl der Einsamkeit verschwindet
dann für einen kurzen Moment
ich habe das Gefühl mir wird gleich
schwarz vor augen Mirko wie geht es dann
weiter ich meine vom Jugendlichen mit
Tötungsfantasien bis hin zur
eigentlichen Tat und Kannibalismus
Vergehen ja immerhin fast 30 Jahre ja
das stimmt niemand hat sich ja auch nur
im Ansatz vorstellen können was in armin
Meiwes vor sich geht auch sexuell ist er
nach außen unauffällig er beschreibt
sich selbst als bisexuell und macht
seine ersten Erfahrungen sowohl mit
Mädchen als auch mit Jungs dabei
geschieht nichts was durchblicken lässt
wonach er sich innerlich sehend
während der zwölf Jahre die er bei der
Bundeswehr ist ist er mit einer Frau
verlobt aber die Beziehung zerbricht zu
einer weiteren engen Verbindung mit
anderen Partnerinnen kommt es danach
nicht mehr der Wunsch nach jemandem der
ihn aus seiner inneren Einsamkeit
herausholt bleibt unerfüllt nichts kommt
auch nur annähernd an seine
Wunschvorstellung ran die Verschmelzung
zweier Seelen
nach dem Tod seiner Mutter 1999 fängt er
mehr und mehr an sich mit dem Tod
auseinander zu setzen
sein Wunsch jemanden zu verspeisen
wächst und wächst
zu dieser Zeit stößt er bei seiner
Recherche im Internet auf Foren für
Kannibalismus
darauf muss man erstmal kommen es ist ja
das eine etwas als Fantasie im Kopf zu
haben und das andere ist raus in die
Welt zu tragen um sich dann aktiv darum
zu bemühen es wahr werden zu lassen bis
heute betont er zwar immer wieder dass
er hätte er als Jugendlicher Hilfe
bekommen oder hätte er sich früher
mitteilen können ist nie so weit
gekommen wäre aber hätte hätte und Armin
majus scheint allem Auftreten nach dem
sehr kluger Mann zu sein der durchaus
unterscheiden kann was richtig und was
falsch ist ab dem Moment in dem er aktiv
in den Chat Räumen nach einem echten
Opfer sucht ist aus der Fantasie auch
schon Realität geworden
zunächst schreibt Armin malwes mit
seiner privaten echten Mailadresse mit
anderen Chatroom Teilnehmern später
nimmt er das Alias Franky an um anonym
zu bleiben die Chats beginnen mit
Fantasien so möchte zum Beispiel einen
Matteo aus Italien zu Tode geprügelt
werden hier bleibt es bei einem reinen
Chatverlauf mit einem Jörg trifft sich
Armin mehrmals Jörg schreibt Armin dass
er einen seiner verhassten
Arbeitskollegen essen möchte und danach
selbst von Meiwes verspeist werden will
auch hier bleibt es bei Gesprächen über
eine mögliche Tat die beiden treffen
sich und stellen in einem Hotelzimmer
eine Schlachtung nach
maiwis malt mit einem Buntstift auf
Jörgs Körper wo er ihn wie schneiden
oder stechen würde und welche
Körperteile wie weiter verarbeitet
werden könnten
ich zitiere mal bis mal aus einem
Interview
da könnte man ein Bratenstück draus
machen aus dem Rückenstück eine
Lachsrolle oder aus dem Schenkel ein
Schnitzel
das hört sich an wie Fiktion das ist so
mega gruselig aber bis dahin halt immer
noch reine Fantasie und unter Fetisch
und nicht als Straftat zu verbuchen als
Armin alias Frankie im Netz dann auf
Brandes alias carto trifft wird es
schnell konkret dann ist es klar der
meins Ernst hier ein kleiner Auszug aus
dem Chatverlauf kurz bevor es zum
Treffen gekommen ist Kato soll folgendes
geschrieben haben
dann hoffe ich bloß dass du nicht
schlapp machst das wirklich durchziehen
kannst und somit kein Problem damit hast
mich um die Ecke zu bringen soll ja für
dich kein Alptraum nach der Erfüllung
des Traumes werden
von mir wird keiner wissen wohin ich
verschwunden bin ich bin überhaupt nicht
nervös nur tierisch geil darauf endlich
mein Lebensziel zu erreichen
solltest vielleicht doch eine
Videokamera mitlaufen lassen damit du es
noch einmal genießen kannst
ich werde dich sowieso nicht mehr
verlassen zumindest nicht komplett
ich glaube wenn es Dir so gefällt wie du
es dir vorstellst werde ich auch nicht
lange allein im Gefrierfach sein da ein
Teil von mir sowieso bei dir bleibt als
Nährstoff in deinen Zellen werde ich ja
sowieso dabei sein wenn du den nächsten
einlädst
spätestens jetzt wäre der Zeitpunkt
gewesen alles abzublasen aber wie wir
wissen haben sich Mais umbrandes
entschieden dass durchzuziehen Karte
nimmt Urlaub von der Arbeit als
Ingenieur bei Siemens Bucht ein
Zugticket von Berlin nach Kassel und
Frankie soll ihm am Bahnhof abholen
Mirko ich denke es ist an der Zeit zur
Zeit zu kommen
der Zug erreicht in Kasseler
Hauptbahnhof am 9 märz 2001 vormittags
gegen 10 Uhr 15
nachdem Haus in Rotenburg angekommen
sind zieht Brand es sich im Wohnzimmer
direkt aus und soll maiwis mit den
Worten
bewundere dein Essen zum Sex eingeladen
haben
nachdem beide dann erstmal einen Kaffee
getrunken haben ging es hoch in den
vorbereiteten Schlachtraum und zur Sache
Brandis hat sich gewünscht dass Mavis
ihn beim Sex das Fleisch von den Knochen
beißt und hatte sich schon vorab extra
ein Bild von Armin majus Gebiss schicken
lassen um sicherzustellen dass das
kräftig genug sein könnte
schnell wurde jedoch klar es klappt
nicht Brandes beschwert sich beides seid
solasch und beiße nicht fest genug zu
auch brandisehnlichster Wunsch das majus
ihm den Penis abbeißt musste verworfen
werden zunächst
boah wir müssen uns hier noch mal kurz
vors innere Auge rufen es sind zwei
erwachsene Männer die sich treffen in
dem Wissen einer soll sterben wir können
von Brandes nicht mehr erfahren wie er
sich bei all dem Gefühl hat aber für
meivis lief es wohl nicht so ab wie er
sich das vorgestellt hat er betont auch
immer wieder dass er nicht sexuell
motiviert gehandelt hat sondern auf die
ultimative Vereinigung gehofft hat das
Füllen seiner inneren Leere und das Ende
seiner Einsamkeit nachdem der Sex wieder
für Brandes noch für malvis befriedigen
war hätte man ja auch hier immer noch
abbrechen können
[Musik]
beide fahren sogar noch zurück zum
Bahnhof Brandes kauft sich sein
Rückfahrticket und überlegt es sich dann
doch noch anders
armin Meiwes besorgt dann in einer
Apotheke Schlaftabletten und Hustensaft
damit möchte Brandes sich betäuben und
dann soll es statt mit dem Zähnen mit
einem Messer weitergehen sie fahren
wieder zurück nach Rotenburg und kommen
gegen 15:30 Uhr nachmittags wieder im
Schlachtraum an
oben im Raum liegt Bernd sich benebelt
von Medikamenten nackt ins Bett gegen 18
Uhr 15 verlangt er obwohl er noch wach
ist dass Marvis ihm nun den Penis
abtrennt
dabei läuft die Kamera und zeichnet
alles auf
Bernd steht am Tisch das Glied auf der
Tischplatte armin Meiwes hat aus der
Küche ein Fleischermesser geholt
er schneidet los oder besser er versucht
es es braucht mehrere Versuche und ein
neues Messer bis das Körperteil
schließlich abgetrennt ist
nachdem malvis Ernst Wunde verbunden hat
setzen sich beide an den Tisch
weil der Verzehr vom rohen Fleisch nicht
klappt Bad mal wisst in abgetrennten
Penis für Brandes in der Pfanne aber
auch das scheint für beide Männer nicht
so befriedigend wie ursprünglich
vorgestellt
entschuldige mal aber was heißt denn
hier bitte nicht befriedigend dass diese
ganze Geschichte nicht schön und fluffig
wird das war ja wohl zu erwarten es ist
auch kaum nachzuvollziehen wie man so
einen perversen Plan durchhalten kann
mit so viel Schmerz und Blut dabei war
aber eins bleibt bestehen beide weichen
nicht vom ursprünglichen Plan ab Bernd
Brandes betont auch jetzt weiter dass er
kein Notarzt will Armin meides lässt
also eine warme Badewanne ein und
Brandes legt sich hinein übrigens ist
dieser Moment der erste in dem beide
Männer ihre echten Namen austauschen aus
Kato wird Bernd und das Franky Armin
nach zweieinhalb Stunden steigt Bernd
Brandes aus der Wanne bricht aber
bewusstlos zusammen Armin maiwest liegt
ihn daraufhin erst ins Bett und bringt
ihn dann in den Schlachtraum dort
fixiert der Bart auf dem Tisch und holt
alle Utensilien dazu besser Seile
stricke und auf die Kamera wird
positioniert und eingeschaltet
nach einiger Zeit ist sich Armin Meiwes
sicher dass Bernd Brandes verstorben ist
und sticht zu erst in den Hals dann
arbeitet er sich anhand einer
ausgedruckten Schlacht Anleitung durch
den Körper durch
Maifest beschreibt das Gefühl später als
grausig
Hass Wut und Glück alles zur gleichen
Zeit aber
er bricht nicht ab sein Opfer wird
ausgeweidet halbiert ausgewaschen und
aufgehängt danach fällt armin Meiwes
todmüde ins Bett
das ist echt es ist es ist echt zu viel
für mich wirklich das ist so schwer zu
ertragen ich meine ist ja auch schwer
anstrengend er hat immerhin einen
Menschen zerlegt und das sehr präzise er
legt alles fallen säuberlich in
Portionen seine Gefriertruhe und
beschriftet die Pakete mit dem Inhalt
Schnitzel Gulasch oder auch Schinken die
Knochen und unverwertbare Überreste
werden im Garten verscharrt
für sein erstes Gericht machte es sich
schön er deckt den Tisch mit dem guten
Geschirr stellt Kerzen auf und verspeist
Rumpsteak mit prinzesskartoffeln und
Rosenkohl
maiwis hat Hände Füße und Kopf von
Brandes erst nicht vergraben sondern
auch in die Truhe gelegt als sich dann
aber irgendwann Besuche ankündigt
begräbt da auch diese auf dem Grundstück
jetzt aber mit einer feierlichen
Zeremonie malvis ist ein Gläubiger Mann
er betet also erneut sein lieblings-
der Herr ist mein Hirte nichts wird mir
fehlen
ja und vielleicht wäre dieses Verbrechen
auch tatsächlich unaufgeklärt geblieben
denn das Verschwinden von Bernd Brandis
wird zunächst nicht mit Meiwes in
Verbindung gebracht aber Armin majus
hört nicht auf die Vereinigung und
Befriedigung die er sich erhofft hat ist
nicht eingetreten er macht weiter und
treibt sich nach wie vor in den
Kannibalismus Chatroom
er schaltet eine Kontaktanzeige die
ungefähr wie folgt gelautet haben soll
junger Mann zum Schlachten gesucht bist
du zwischen 18 und 30 Jahren alt dann
bewirb dich mit Angabe von alter Größe
und Gewicht möglichst mit Foto
daraufhin meldet sich ein Innsbrucker
Student bei der Polizei und schwärzt
Armin meivis alias Franky an es kommt zu
einer Hausdurchsuchung
und nach und nach finden Sie alles am 10
dezember 2002 stellt sich Meiwes seinem
Anwalt und legt ein vollständiges
Geständnis ab
nach seiner Festnahme ruft er seinen
Bruder an seine Schwägerin geht ans
Telefon und fragt scherzhaft hast du
eine Leiche im Keller und malvis
antwortet nein im Kühlschrank
wenn die wüsste
es folgen mehrere prozessstage und
diverse Gerichtsurteile schlussendlich
wird Armin meivis am 9 mai 2006 zu einer
lebenslangen Haftstrafe verurteilt wegen
Mordes und Störung der Totenruhe bis
heute doch der mittlerweile 61-Jährige
Mann aus dem Gefängnis rauszukommen im
August 2020 ist das letzte Gesuch
abgelehnt worden
Nadja Niesen Sprecherin der
Staatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt hat das so
begründet die vorzeitige Haft Entlassung
wird abgelehnt weil ihm keine günstige
Legalprognose gestellt werden können
viel mehr wird er nach dem Ergebnis
eines forensisch psychiatrischen
Gutachtens weiterhin als für die
Allgemeinheit gefährlich angesehen da
auch noch vielen Jahren der
therapeutischen Behandlung im
Strafvollzug keine ausreichende
Auseinandersetzung mit der Tat und ihren
Hintergrund stattgefunden hat
nach diesem Beschluss liegt Armin meives
Beschwerde ein vergeblich der Kannibale
von Rotenburg bleibt vorerst weiter
hinter Gittern
boah mir platzt der Kopf was für eine
krass gruselige Geschichte ist es
einfach so abgefahren ich finde es ist
ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen ob es
sich hier wirklich um einen Mord handelt
weil beide wollten es und genau das
nimmt bei mir auch dieses Gewicht wieder
raus weißt du weil ich weiß da läuft
jetzt keiner rum und hat jetzt irgendwie
wie wild Leute abgeschlachtet sondern
man hat sich geeinigt und ist
durchgezogen es war auch Respekt an
dieses Durchhaltevermögen weil die
hatten ja so viele Möglichkeiten da
auszusteigen aber sie haben es eiskalt
durchgezogen
was mich da am meisten gruselt ist in
dieser abgerunde der menschlichen Psyche
hervorzudringen weil mir wäre das so
nicht in den Kopf gekommen das ist sowas
überhaupt gibt und das öffnet bei mir
schon wieder ganz andere Türen im Kopf
wo es mir echt grauen
eins muss ich noch unbedingt sagen dass
es so abgefahren dass der Mai ist ja
nicht rüberkommt wie ein typischer
Mensch Interesse so wie ich mir den in
meinem Kopf wie so ein Viren total
abgedrehten Typen den man das ja auch
noch ansieht vorstellt Armin meivis
kommt in Interviews rüber wie ein ganz
normaler Mensch ja sympathisch gebildet
überhaupt nicht auffällig Mirko was
macht das mit dir
oh mein Gott also ich finde diesen Fall
absolut verstörend ich muss nach unserem
Podcast glaube ich erstmal frische Luft
schnappen ich meine die Verbrechen die
wir hier behandeln sind allesamt
wirklich tragisch und grausam und
natürlich will man einleiten nicht über
das andere Stellen die Schilderungen in
diesem Fall sind einfach nur schwer zu
ertragen es ist unglaublich was ist da
für eine Parallelwelt gibt das scheinen
sich offenbar tausende Menschen mit
einem Fetisch für Kannibalismus im Netz
zu tummeln okay ich meine heute gibt es
wahrscheinlich nichts was es nicht gibt
aber was tun die wenn die ihren Fetisch
ausleben wollen da kann man nur hoffen
dass die Fantasie eine Fantasie bleibt
und Natalie du hast vollkommen Recht
Armin Mais wirkt überhaupt nicht wählen
Menschenfresser oder mordender
Straftäter in einem Interview dass ich
von ihm gesehen habe da erscheint er
eher wieder nette Mann von ihm an man
sieht ihm überhaupt nicht an dass er
irgendwie verrückte ist oder
durchgedreht denn wenn er von der Tat
selbst spricht und dabei gewitzelt und
so ganz locker erzählt dann fällt mir
einfach auf dass er das überhaupt nicht
wirklich reflektiert er weiß nach außen
hin dass die Gesellschaft diese Tat
verurteilt aber er selbst rechtfertigt
das die ganze Zeit damit dass er sagt
Herr Brandes habe das so gewollt ja eine
Tötung auf Verlangen aber selbst wenn
man von einer Tötung auf Verlangen
spricht dann muss er doch gewusst haben
dass das falsch ist
und hätte das ganze einfach stoppen
müssen
und so unglaublich solche Sexfantasie
noch klingen solange diese Fantasie in
eine Fantasie bleiben und niemand zu
Schaden kommt dann mag das okay sein
glücklicherweise wurde er dann halt
irgendwann verpetzt und so ist das Ganze
ans Licht gekommen und es gab keine
weiteren Opfer
Mirko war aber zum Glück können wir
sagen dass heutzutage kein Jugendlicher
mehr mit solchen Gedanken alleine
bleiben muss es gibt genug Anlaufstellen
man kann sich austauschen so dass sowas
gar nicht erst zur Tat kommen muss
Armin meides sitzt im Gefängnis und da
wird er voraussichtlich bis zum Ende
seiner Tage auch nicht mehr rauskommen
das ist gut so ja
tja das war's für heute wir danken euch
fürs zuhören und hoffen dass ihr bei der
nächsten Folge wieder dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko
und eure Natalie
den Fall des Kannibalen von Rotenburg
haben wir zusammengetragen mit
zahlreichen Artikeln der Bild-Zeitung
sowie Auszügen aus Artikeln in der HNA
Stern Welt und dem Dokumentarfilm der
Kannibale von Rotenburg das Interview
ungekürzt und unzensiert
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Heiler Produktion Marvin schwarz